[Music]
this is Bob Linde welcome to a new world
as humanly possible
the period in the city that's really
another water what are your choices the
next world war is gonna be fought out of
a water where and when I was I need two
questions that need answering we're
living in 2018 cars should be flying by
now but no it's a water crisis if
someone looks over the wall and see
you've still got a green lawn you're in
big trouble the water is not going to be
a short-term issue if it was a
short-term issue I don't think I would
have put a ball hold up to go and get
our own water this prison time to be
down to 50 litres a day for postage is
really nothing so I think it's worth all
the pain and suffering imagine the day
when there is no water in that tap I
mean it's not just about you know
drinking water you can buy drinking
water but the health issues and the
hygiene oh I mean it's awful not being
able to flush your toilet much faith in
the government I don't think they've
actually got a plan and I think that's
why a lot of us have taken it into our
own hands to go and get our own water
[Music]
collect as much as you can and tonight
to use all that water for all your job
is you saving today's water already
today on Wednesdays which adds about
water matters and everybody is talking
about the Cape Town with a crisis taking
a look at the drive levels at the moment
our dam levels are 23% full at the
moment but of course it's difficult to
use that last 10% so they're actually
only 13% full that is a zero this is the
lowest rainfall we've had in four
hundred years for a government making
that kind of day zero announcement has
massive political risk in it people
suddenly blaming you that you can't
manage this properly etc etc something
like a drought comes along three years
in a row it really does get you to think
differently to behave differently we
cannot use water like we used to it is
serious and it still will be serious and
it's serious right into our winter
before we can really reassess and if we
get the same rainfall as last year then
it's going to be just a series we've got
a city that's growing apples what
economies that you want to grow we've
got high unemployment rates in our
country we need to grow the economy and
to grow the economy we need air water as
part of it there's absolutely nothing I
can do without water the survival of my
business depends on water my survival
depends on water my children they depend
on this water before the drought I used
to have a pipe and the high pressure
yeah but now the municipality guys they
asked us to use the budgets I used to
make 15 and more cars a day so now plus
minus 7 cars so you know that you see
the difference
in South Africa there poor people are
always a target if they want to blame
for miss usage of water they will blame
you maybe if they can just be in my
shoes maybe they will feel what I'm
feeling but unfortunately they can't do
what they have the salary which we don't
they have benefits which we don't if you
don't come here we don't eat
youngster CPT's you what an awesome
young guy in town he is regarded as one
of the most important South African MCS
of his generation he's rapping he's a
hip-hop artist and he describes his
sound as cop starts Cape Town man
youngster CBC has been going around to
schools he's been inspiring the youth
he's been educating them about the
importance of saving water we're
witnessing sometimes people's true
colors we witnessing the desperation we
witnessing the measures that people will
go to to get water
they have been fights they have been
arguments they've been you know
sometimes almost like looting to a
certain group people are just willing to
go steal water now stealing some people
are willing to crack deps open in the
street just so they can fill a bucket
and a run I know what it's like to be
spoken at he said Oh spoken to I come
here with a different approach I come
here and I dressed him as the equals you
know they know a lot more they exposed
to a lot more at a young age I mean are
they dealing with the water crisis all
the pressure is on them it wasn't the
problem they were born a few years ago
they did not create this problem but now
it's up to them to come up with a
solution
now
[Applause]
that's it
you see them on the TV
the water
[Applause]
our parents don't have a lot of manual
work so if the if the money's up we
they're gonna get money to buy us
clothes and stuff I just wanted to say
all the people myself okay darling we
stink
[Music]
this is the the mud the mud River the
Red Sea that's just arrived here they
hit an underground cave I mean is their
point of opening the blinds there is no
point no lights coming through but funny
thing is that I look at this and we were
just joking with some other friends the
other day I said you know we've all got
the state-of-the-art bottom Jesus is
Italian marble and all those on these
beautiful bathrooms and now we can't use
them you know that's the boss bucket of
famous buckets with the toilet paper
goes in no toilet paper in the loo and
then that's the jacuzzi which is not
usable
sadly you can see it's got everything in
it you can't use the water we all are
OCD in one way or another
and walking in mud and having to watch
your feet wherever you go I hate it it's
very disturbing and an it has been
really upset because she keeps
questioning whether we did the right
thing
I think to myself it's like when you
waiting for an exam result than you said
anything did I get an age that I get a
piece of that part of ourselves you know
and you're sitting there and your heart
is actually your freshener waiting for
the results and I think Ella and I knew
without among social taboos on window
and ornaments okay
encinia system mrs. O'Bannon en avant
wanna um Santa Anita and are about como
el shamah Samantha thought whom I did so
frantic muffin has fallen in line happy
tape sorry bombs and then color with
their proper balance Sunday lol actual
Bertram about the ganja and sound
[Music]
our daily consumption is currently at
511 million liters a day I don't know
about you Bobby I skipped my shower this
morning
yes oh no don't be like that
I'm gonna bounce one liter a day I've
definitely been scared about what would
happen when the taps run dry what's
going to happen when we have to stand in
long queues and line up for water you
know you wonder is it going to be civil
or our fights going to break out am I
going to be safe are people going to
attack you for the little bit of water
that you just collected I mean generally
quite a mild-mannered person but it
makes my blood boil to see when people
are wasting water especially since you
know at home I'm trying my best but
Yahoo was driving the other day through
a certain neighborhood and there was
somebody just hosing em they're paving
down with the garden hose and I've never
done this in my life before I was
actually quite shocked at my reaction
but I want down the window I know a toy
you know I'm supposed to be doing that
and he had this you know devil-may-care
kind of attitude and it really really
annoyed me so I reported him but you
know there is a hotline where you can
report people and I think you should
because they should be consequences one
thing that's really changed my life is
saving my shower water so we're down to
one and a half minute showers at the
moment every last drop of that water is
captured in the bath we then take the
buckets as you can see over here and we
scoop up all the water it did take some
getting used to both my fiance and our
very private people
so our bathroom antics were very much
kept to ourselves and now having to
leave the urine in the toilet pan for
the next person to discover and then you
know pee on top of has taken a bit of
getting used to
there was a time when we were really
really really worried into that today
zero was going to be here and so we went
and bought a whole lot of water in case
of emergencies
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and because of plummeting supply and
skyrocketing demand water shortage is
fast becoming the norm of the world over
and this means that we all going to have
to educate ourselves about using our
most valuable resource a lot more
mindfully we've all heard the
jaw-dropping stats by now it takes a 80
litres of water to produce just a 1
kilogram of steel and 140 litres of
water to make your cup of coffee a
reality this morning so now that means
our water crisis is really a classes of
all things that need water and of course
here in Cape Town we've been forced by a
necessity to come up with many
innovations to stretch our water supply
yeah exactly we don't see the water like
we used to maybe three years ago exactly
and for small 90.4 FM I'm Bobby Brown
with the i-smile report if you take a
global view of water and the way that in
our relationship with water there's that
amount of water on the earth it's finite
but the amount of people on the earth is
not finite they're growing all the time
not only that but the pool of usable
water which we call potable is actually
diminishing because of pollution so
you've got the water pool during there
to your epochs the the population doing
that that elastic is going to at some
stage snap we saw this coming 12 years
ago
Kurt Kurt so the chart has changed the
volume of business we're doing I mean we
sold out at every machine we've got
people have suddenly jumped on to the
fact that it's actually true that there
is no water so there gets drawn in by
big fans and across a cold coil over
here and then it's collected in this
storage pointer so this over here was
humanity a couple of hours ago huge
opportunity has come out of adversity
however there's a lot of people in a lot
of pain
we haven't even felt the effect on meat
supply on vegetable supply on the cost
of living and we've got politicians that
are standing up saying don't worry catch
on everything is fine until 10,000
people take over the International
Airport why until petroleum can't be
made anymore
so going forward the world is going to
be a very thirsty place and the only
thing that's driving it unfortunately is
that rich people don't sleep well when
poor people are thirsty and it's the
threat and the insecurity of an uprising
and political fortunes and futures of
countries within the next few years will
be changed because of a thing called
water
[Music]
[Music]
almost there today's the
huge anxiety sleepless nights if the
water is there then it's worth it
because all this is redeemable but if
there's no water and you've done all
this in vain and you've spent a fortune
and all you've got is a mess I think
that is like nervous breakdown stuff
I don't think I've ever been so stressed
in my life
isn't it amazing what a relief in
Nanakuli let's let's say thank you to
Jesus Jesus we just want to thank you
for this wonderful gift of water that we
can have a swimming pool we can have a
garden and we don't have to worry we
could have a nice boss
six meters yes and have enough water for
your house fantastic more than enough
[Music]
I think it's going to be a whole new way
of life I'm pretty certain no one's ever
gonna revert back to where we were just
because it's happening a cave time it
doesn't mean it's a lost city is going
to happen we're the cars that fell off
the horse here I don't foresee any
improvement it's going to continue and
I'm worried well Cape Town day zero
might have been pushed back so far that
we might not even see it in 2018 but it
is still definitely looming they are a
hundred and twenty cities around the
world that are very very serious water
situation this is not the only Cape
Town's problem this is so many local
[Music]
[Music]